Attorney General William bar says he is
not convinced by his own watchdogs
review of the investigation to the Trump
campaigns ties to Russia the Justice
Department inspector general found the
FBI was justified in opening the
investigation and found no evidence of
political bias but the report did find
that the agents made a series of errors
Catherine Harridge has read the report
now and has more details for us
Catherine good morning to you House
response playing out so far well Gail
the report matters now because of its
political implications and there's
enough in it for both sides to claim
they were right Republicans say this
report exposes wrongdoing by the FBI and
Democrats say it proves the
investigation was legitimate
it's everything that a lot of people
thought it would be except far worse
president Trump was quick to seize on
some of the report's findings they
fabricated evidence and they lied to the
courts and they did all sorts of things
to have it go their way the nearly 440
page Justice Department report found
significant inaccuracies and omissions
in all of the surveillance warrant
applications for former Trump campaign
aide Carter Page in a statement Paige
called the findings evidence of an
egregious overreach by the intelligence
community but the report also found no
documentary or testimonial evidence that
political bias drove the FBI's
decision-making inspector general
Michael Horowitz said the FBI was on
solid ground when it opened the July
2016 counterintelligence probe into
alleged coordination between the Trump
campaign and Russia there are actions
described in this report that I consider
unacceptable and unrepresentative FBI
director Christopher Rea acknowledged
FBI personnel made significant mistakes
but agree with the major findings saying
there was no quote deep state conspiracy
that's not a term I would ever use to
describe our work force and I think it's
an affront to them but in a division
within the department his boss attorney
general bar disputed the findings saying
the investigation into the Trump
campaign was launched on the thinnest of
suspicions and there was an interesting
twist that came out of the report and it
has to do with Christopher Steele if you
remember Steele compiled that in
dossier with unproven details that the
President and Republicans have
repeatedly attacked according to the
report Steele told the inspector general
that before he began his research he was
favorably disposed towards the Trump
family and even had a personal
relationship believed to be with Ivanka
Trump the report did criticize the FBI's
reliance on Steele's dossier which was
used by agents to justify parts of the
investigation
saying much of its information Anthony
was uncorroborated very interesting
Catherine thank you